he's been called a savior by some and a
dangerous political operative by others
Steve Bannon is a man who's rebranded
racism as nationalism and now he is
Trump's chief strategist and he was a
key player in getting the Donald into
the White House hey I'm Tarek and we're
gonna walk you through how someone with
such a low profile and ties to white
supremacy rose to become one of the most
powerful men in the United States after
years in prep school and later
graduating from Virginia Tech Bannon
enlisted in the military where he served
from the late 70s to early 80s during
this time Bannon grew disillusioned with
then President Jimmy Carter he felt
Carter's sole focus in the Persian Gulf
was aimed towards protecting the US oil
interests from the nation's cold war
enemy the Soviet Union but in 1980 there
was a turning point in u.s. politics
California Governor Ronald Reagan came
to power after inspiring millions with
the slogan let's make America great
again
sound familiar Bannon left the Navy in
1983 to pursue his MBA at Harvard he
would eventually find his way to one of
the biggest financial firms on Wall
Street goldman sachs not and left the
banking giant to start his own firm
Bannon and Coe the upstart connected big
money financed Sears with huge Hollywood
projects and then 9/11 out Bannon threw
all of his energy into producing and
directing his own documentaries but
these weren't your average Netflix
movies the liberal media don't matter to
me
Republican establishment don't matter to
me to hell with the establishment
because the establishment has put us in
this position
from 2004 to 2012 Bannon directed nine
films his inspiration Nazi propaganda
filmmaker Leni Riefenstahl Riefenstahl
collaborated with Adolf Hitler in the
1900s to create films glorifying the
Nazi Party throughout his career
bannon's colleagues have described his
work ethic as very intense and parts of
his personal life were just as intense
Bannon was married a few times the
second wife was Mary Louise Picard she
made headlines when reporters dug up a
domestic violence report that she filed
in 1996
several years later Steve and Mary
Louise divorced and he married Diane
Clos Hesse Diane was an activist for a
new political presence growing across
the u.s. the t-point banning identified
with the group's mistrust in federal
government and agreed with rolling back
social welfare programs Steve and Diane
also called it quits ending their
marriage in 2009 that same year Barack
Obama was sworn in as the first black
president and the tea party hit the
national stage during the 2010 midterm
elections Bannon released a film battle
for America to fire up Tea Party
supporters I shudder to imagine what an
unchecked unlimited Obama radicalism
would be like in the next two years he
has truly awakened to sleeping giant to
a point where they are determined to
take back America
and balance films were effective
combined with the landmark Supreme Court
case Citizens United tea party-backed
Republicans won big 44 seats to be exact
in 2011
Bannen met Andrew Breitbart and the two
became fast friends now bright bar.com
was a conservative news organization
that pander to people who felt that Fox
News was the establishment Andrew
Breitbart died in 2012
Steve Bannon took over and helped
amplify anti-black anti-muslim and
anti-immigrant sentiment he used
Breitbart to cater to white supremacists
in that same year conservative activists
and citizens united architect David
bossy would introduce ban into Donald
Trump the two reportedly hit it off and
it was at a time when Trump was in the
early stages of considering a 2012
presidential run the country is doing
very poorly it just can't do much worse
we're not respected anywhere in the
world I am seriously thinking about it
2012 wouldn't be Trump's year but this
Breitbart fan would find a 2016 campaign
leader in Banat remember when the Access
Hollywood video was released with
Trump's misogynistic comments
it was bannon's idea to deflect the
outrage by inviting Bill Clinton's
sexual accusers to a press conference
and the second presidential debate
political maneuvers like that earned
Bannon respect the trust of Donald Trump
and ultimately the coveted chief
strategist position lawmakers on the
left and right were horrified and urged
the Trump campaign to reconsider
as chief strategist Steve Bannon has the
ear of the president and access to the
full resources of the stake this is a
man who has elevated far-right Tea Party
ideals to the highest office of the land
he mainstreamed what was once fringe to
be front and center now we can't predict
what a trump presidency will look like
but we can expect Steve Bannon to
empower a platform of white supremacy a
platform that now has a seat at the
table
you